come to the question of the economy then
apart from broken britain one of your
slogans last time was that the country
was overwhelmed in debt overwhelmed was
the words you use how much money have
you borrowed but we have cut the budget
deficit in half as a share or have you
borrowed what open the key thing is the
amount of money you borrow every year
the deficit you know what is it that is
down in half I know that we have
borrowed a lot of money because the
deficit adds to your debt if you know
which that's what the figure is where
you're going to tell me Jeremy please I
am Samir 500 billion pounds but that is
a lot less than the previous government
was borrowing but now it is and it's
more than the premium overdraw road the
wet look the annual overdraft the
deficit has come down by one half as a
share of GDP and debt debt the total
stock the debt as a share of our
national income is now falling now we
haven't finished the job we have been
working to a plan and the British people
have been working incredibly hard to
that plan of turning the economy around
getting the deficit down having public
services that we can afford and creating
jobs and livelihoods for all our people
that is what we have been doing now if
you're saying we haven't gone fast
enough to cut the deficit I would agree
we need to complete the job but all my
political opponents have been saying we
should borrow more we should spend more
we should tax more that's the
alternative that you faced with with Ed
Miliband is merely the chasm between
what was said and what was actually done
let's